good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy arguably i
think one of the best days of the week
thursday we can finally wish you a happy
thursday after talking about it all week
sometimes we talk about the days of the
week more than other times this week was
particularly day heavy yeah no and
that's life like sometimes the week
rolls by and sometimes it's like oh my
god monday and then
tuesday wait no
wednesday
it couldn't possibly be thursday heart
eye emoji
friday breathing out emoji a sigh of
relief yeah so we're here on a thursday
which is exciting there's so much to
discuss today
we are kind of like matching
like are we gonna hit the links after
this
are we gonna go to the country club
together after this um probably not
because the only country club we wanted
to be a member of rejected us
so probably not probably not but if
anybody wants to invite us to their
country club for lunch today we are
dressed for the occasion i can clear my
schedule easily actually i have an
important doctor's appointment
haraldson's four-month checkup
a-a-a-a-a-a-a
does that mean you're officially out of
the sids phase right isn't it zero to
three months so no i think sids is like
all baby sids is the scariest [ __ ]
thing like of all time i learned about
it with olivia i'm like this is twisted
yeah
very scary like i didn't expect you to
bring up sids no i'm sorry i just like i
remember being quite taken about
learning what sids was yeah
i don't even want to say what it is it's
like a terrible acronym you know yeah no
it's it's all bad but um but harold is
doing that
yeah he's doing great except for you
know eating it every hour on the hour
last night keeping his mom me up and
busy you probably don't need to go to
the doctor because i could tell you he's
in the 99th percentile for
anti-lovingness that's true he's in the
99th percentile for being such a good
boy good boy love sweet he's in the 50th
percentile for keeping his mother awake
at night
he's in the 99th percentile of having
excellent taste in favorite aunties and
he's also in the 99th percentile and
just being the youtube man i ever did
see he's also in the 99th percentile for
being the best brother to bring himself
they're the cutest brothers a little
jealous but who who sibling rivalry
sibling rivalry now i get it we never
really had sibling rivalry like i always
say i'll read in books about like
sisters and they're like oh you know how
sisters are and i'm like no i don't this
vibes are stingy
the books that i read are about like two
hot brothers who like
like are always competing for a girl you
know but i meant to text you last night
but i actually like didn't want to blow
up your spot but i was on goodreads so i
was seeing like all the books you've
been going through and like you weren't
lying when you said you were reading
erotica like you're reading like the
novels with the covers of like the guy
with abs okay advertise on kindle so
you're talking about one book in
particular i took a screenshot catching
you or something i took a screenshot and
normally like yes i
i stay chasing love chasing love
catching you whatever i stay away from
books with covers like that just
please you're really blowing up as well
sorry i just want everyone to know what
i'm talking about well honestly i stay
away from books with covers like that
because it's like what are you doing but
i was on tick tock and people were like
quaking over this book and so i was like
oh cute and then i was like this is the
book it's giving like danielle steele
like of course i was like am i actually
going to read this and i have to say it
was extremely good until the end like
that was the one that like just
ended in the middle i thought every
summer after was the one with the last
sentence that was the last sentence i
meant like the ending of the book there
wasn't an ending because that's an eight
book series and i'm not going to read
all eight like why not because you'll
screenshot my goodreads and put me on
blast on the podcast i just i already
did you already put yourself on blast i
just didn't realize how honest you were
being like when we read it happened one
summer like we said it's erotica but
there's cartoon people on the cover no
jackie by the way
it happened when summer is the same
level of erotica as the book with the
cover with the naked people okay but you
could be fooled by the cover because
it's cartoons you know i'm definitely
thinking of deleting my goodreads and
starting like a new private one
but then like you're doing something
shameful it's the same thing
it's the same thing of like spotify like
yeah there are certain platforms that
need not be social you know yeah not
share so much information like i don't
need people on spotify to see what music
i'm listening to what other podcasts
like i'm seeing people talking [ __ ]
about us on like that's what i do and
that's why i will never listen to a
podcast i don't even know if my spotify
is private like i always check that it's
private but i have like anxiety that
it's not i will never listen to a
podcast on spotify no that's what's
weird like showing what podcasts you're
listening to most of the time i'm
listening to just things i'm proud of
things i would talk about on the show
but sometimes i'm like listening to
embarrassing like wanting to see what's
going on yeah in the community yeah of
course and it's like
is nothing private anymore no nothing is
sacred like not every app has to be a
social media app like normalize having
private media apps okay okay not social
anti-social media apps you should start
one
totally
totally uh we were just talking about
your book for a second i had something
one more thing i wanted to say but
it's neither here nor there you're gonna
get a lot of that today because your
girl was up all night with [ __ ] your
girl was up all night i almost was gonna
text you and say
podcast only episode in studio because i
didn't want to put on makeup because my
skin is like so bad from the lack of
sleep have you also have you seen this
eye oh you know that happened to me once
you see this eye it's been like red for
days no it has like a little something
that happened to me once when i was on
vacation i happened to be on vacation
with a doctor um a doctor oz and he told
me he was totally a doctor yeah he told
me he's totally fine you have nothing to
worry about i'm not worried it's just
but it looked like somebody threw a
piece of glass in my eye yeah yeah yeah
like and everyone like looks i was like
are you okay it looks much worse than it
is that's i didn't feel a thing i didn't
know it was a thing until people on my
instagram were like what the [ __ ] is up
with your eye yeah and it was like a big
purple like blood clot yeah and dr oz
said it was fine so you're fine okay
thanks dr oz for the peace of mind um
today's thursday which means real
housewives of beverly hills recap and i
have actually like many many thoughts i
dare say i'm oozing with thoughts yeah
there's a lot to discuss yeah and
forward to it it was nice to have
something to watch even though
everything is on wednesdays now i know
so give us a break and again if you're
like
waiting for the kardashians recap i'm
not waiting until midnight to watch a tv
show recaps are on friday recaps are on
friday so we can give the girls the time
that they deserve and i have glowing
reviews about the kardashian news show
but like the midnight time slot is not
moved until like 9pm okay but that's
what you said and then i went on my hulu
and it said it's coming out of 12. and
then also i saw some i think maybe liz
high posted like they dropped the
episode early like what are you what is
this so apparently they dropped this
week's episode earlier they did a
podcast a patreon episode like they just
drop when you feel they drop this
episode early and then i go to hulu and
literally it says not available until
12. so
it's so confusing it's so confusing and
that's not gonna work for me me neither
like i'm a regimented queen
i like a schedule a tv guide if you will
and it's not gonna work no we're past
the days of tv guides no i know now
things just drop yeah it's like it's
it's a drop guide yeah it's twisted it
is twisted we need to be prepared to
catch literally um so we've got a great
show five fabulous stories one fabulous
recap and two fabulous girls and two
fabulous bryson stress it's true it's
true she told no lies i told no lies
bryce was doing his jealous brother
thing this morning satiated with him
satiated him with a bully stick that he
finished in point three seconds good
they're getting faster and faster i
think he's swallowing them whole yeah
and then he was a sweet love so
stress we miss you maybe tomorrow will
be a straw day you know
you never know ooh i saw strikes
yesterday
when they go on their walks bryce comes
and picks up theo and then theo goes and
drops off rice and i saw thrice it's
really one of the better parts of my
days it's so sweet their cousin walk
where they could just catch up talk
about the family talk about magnolia
their friend butters is there too
the big poodle
what
nothing
you have thoughts on butters i don't
know like i just i don't know what the
dynamic is between the three of them
like does butters feel excluded because
he's not family family or
is like one of them getting closer with
butters and the other ones feeling
excluded i don't know okay so butters is
this probably like 600 pound poodle that
walks with bryson's rice and like seeing
them all together bryce and stripes are
so small and this poodle is like above
average size maybe it's not a it's a
poodle
it's giving poodle energy it is but it's
like tall
it's a toodle so i want to say two
disparaging things about butter i hope
butter's mom isn't watching so butters
one time in my house all three boys came
to drop off thea or pick up theo i
forget and i saw butters get on his back
two feet and like stand up like a human
being and lunge at bruno
like i do think butter is coming for
chase i think butters has like an
aggressive vibe and you know ever since
that day butters comes to my house to
pick up theo and he wears a muzzle
because he's coming for strikes i'm
telling you i think it's i've never
heard of like an aggressive poodle
it's very bizarre but i'm pretty sure
he's
like not not well yeah
i think they've got a cute dynamic the
three of them and like bruno comes home
happy every day yeah yeah no scratches
like nothing there are other dogs in the
group who like come and go butters is is
it forever yeah but um there are others
we love to larp about the other dogs and
just like like oliver
yeah olive wears a bespoke harness yeah
that is like fitted to a tee it's like
customary oliver is definitely like from
williamsburg like it gives it's giving
brooklyn yeah edgy he's very quaffed
and then there's mystery and mysteries
it's a mystery the dog's name is mystery
and there was like a brief period where
mystery was on every single walk like
multiple times a day and we were like
worried there might be trouble at home
right um but that's again us just
larbing about the dogs in bryson's
triceps group but now we haven't seen
mystery in a while so i think like
things have calmed down or they have
maybe mystery
had a new baby at home and needed to get
out of the house more kind of like what
bryce was doing and now everything's
situated in their brother and sister
it's unclear what the gender of mystery
is yeah it's a gender-neutral history
it's a gender-neutral name so i feel
like mystery is a girl
i honestly i don't know what about
butters
butter's man yeah yeah for sure butter's
like so that's i guess the problem with
having these like stupid dog names like
puddles you know it's like you up to
someone in the street you're like oh my
such a cute dog what's his name and or
what's its name and they're like alex
and you're like hmm
alexandra or alexander because then you
want to be like oh she's so cute and
they have to like you can't use pronouns
for the rest of the interaction yeah
bruno just got a new baby blue harness
which should signal to everyone he is a
boy but apparently zach was with him and
someone was like oh what's his name and
zach was like bruno and they were like
oh that's such a manly name for such
like a feminine looking dog and i was
like it's
bruna is this
is this pedestrian enforcing toxic
gender stereotypes onto bruno at a young
age yeah yeah that's disgusting but he
is brutal sometimes bruno
bruno bruno bruna
[Music]
what's my name what's my name what's the
name um yeah theo wore a pink harness
for most of his life and people were
like you have to start giving him like a
different color because people are gonna
think he's a girl and i'm like do you
think i literally care like
i bought the harness they're like 25
he will wear it until it's worn out and
then i'll get them a different one then
i did orange and i did blue like colors
associating with gender for dogs sorry
not a thing
uh like a little bit but even when theo
wore pink harness like i just saw him as
theo you know i didn't see the harness
and pink went with his color the harness
didn't wear him he wore the harness
he was also influenced by harry styles
on the cover of vogue because that was
like the same week yeah when he was
wearing the dress and he saw like color
and style has no gender right and he was
really like moved by that he was
influenced 100
no so bryce used to wear like all nudes
but then they would get really dirty so
now he's wearing this blue and he looks
fantastic he does the boys look good the
boys are looking good the group is
quaking um and we'll keep you updated on
the
whereabouts and the happenings of
mystery brice thrice olive and butters i
will be shocked if we don't hear from
someone from butter's mom yeah being
like what'd you say yeah about my boy
well we did find butter's mom's
instagram oh well no butters is butters
isn't it
which i assume is run by his mom i still
haven't found his mom it's premium yeah
no she takes great pictures of all three
of them yeah that's how we find out what
our kids are up to yeah so it's nice
it's cute
um so other than
than butters i think we should dive in i
think we should dive in we have some
great stories claudia chose four out of
the five again so you can expect a lot
of fun celebrity fair
and without further a
do we're talking about the crew
do it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
well spring has sprung and we are
updating our homes for spring and
investing in quality pieces that make
any room look and feel complete jenny
kane home has everything you need to
create the home of your dreams from
handmade furniture and kitchen
essentials to pillows and throws that
you can pair with anything so the
pillows and throws that come in linen
and alpaca cashmere they're handcrafted
textiles in versatile cotton and linen
and they're perfect for the sofa bedroom
or an accented edition you can settle
within with the epitome of cozy comfort
the tahoe cashmere throw and the alpaca
basket weave throw they also have
dinnerware and serve wear the pacific
dinnerware and serve wares durable
hardworking and it starts at just 25
their tabletop prices are made for all
types of entertaining they also offer
candles and slippers which are all over
my house their california inspired
scents are coveted by all their handport
in los angeles and their slippers come
in shearling to suede their slippers are
the ultimate indoor indulgence jenny
kane herself is like an iconic stylish
queen so like if you're looking for
decor inspiration i would look none
other than jenny kane home jenny kane
home creates california inspired
classics for any room or mood they're
grounded in natural texture textures
inviting neutrals and these are the
pieces you'll love coming home to check
out the jenny kane ranch which is their
large full-scale interior project in
santa ines that brings up the california
aesthetic to life this remarkable space
was a full gut renovation and you can
follow jenny kane and jenny kane home on
instagram
for all the details if you want to shop
jenny kane home and get 20 off for all
furniture and home decor plus early
products access and much more with jkh
membership join the membership at
jennykaine.com membership or go to
jennycane.com home to create the space
you'll never want to leave that's
j-e-n-n-i-k-a-y-n-e
dot com slash
home today's episode is also brought to
you by little spoon a one-stop shop for
healthy easy meal time and snacking for
your baby toddler and big kid delivered
right to your door little spoon makes
healthy meal time easy at every stage
which saves you hours in your week at a
reasonable price they're also the most
flexible company where you can pause
modify cancel or skip at any time most
of the babies slash kids food at the
grocery store is really processed and
it's often not on the shelf it's often
on the shelf longer than your little
child has been in the world
so the quality new nutrition that our
kids deserve really cannot be found at
the grocery store and that's why little
spoon is making everything fresh and
they use absolutely nothing artificial
it's just like homemade all delivered to
your door and ready in seconds you pop
your meals in the fridge or the freezer
and then use them when you're ready it
is that easy 100 organic cold-pressed
baby food for someone like haraldson so
they really have every stage for the
kids in your life they have a toddler
and kids food line that makes that takes
you through through the tough weaning
stage into the big kid years and they
just launched a line of their on the go
smoothies so all of the recipes taste
absolutely delicious are nutritionally
based balanced and free of junk helping
you set your little one up for a
lifetime of health we have tried
everything it tastes legit great and
your babies your toddlers your teens
they are going to be eating better than
you the best part is that the price is
right with kids meals under five dollars
and baby food and smoothie snacks under
three it makes trying little spoon
really easy and affordable start the
year fresh with little spoon get 50 off
your first order with the code toast at
checkout that's little spoon code toast
at checkout off your first little spoon
order enter code toast little spoon
camper tested counselor approved love
kicks is quaking
kicks is quaking it's freezing in here
today
i'm dressed properly because i'm cold on
the bottom warm on top so i'm balanced
yeah
this thrice pillow is keeping my crotch
really warm so small and frail no i'm
like so easily temperature controlled
because i'm so tiny do you need a
blanket small girl i'm shivering my
bones are popping out
[Laughter]
do you need a blanket yeah
i'll just complain you just wanted to
complain okay
first story britney spears and samus
gary are getting married on thursday
wedding bells are ringing for britney
the singer and her fiance are getting
married thursday at her thousand oaks
california home a source confirms to
page six the pair will tie the knot in
an intimate ceremony surrounded by
approximately 50 close friends and
family members they are told tmz
reported that her brother brian will be
in attendance but her estranged parents
and sister didn't receive invitations
after their fallout over her
conservatorship battle
okay i don't know why i was like
surprised by this i know they're
literally engaged and the point of
getting engaged is to get married i just
thought they were like engaged like for
fun you know yeah a lot of celebrities
get engaged for fun and it's like they
told us they want to get married she
wants to enter conservatives so that
they can get married the conservatorship
ended a few months ago so this actually
is right on time yeah but it still seems
soon no it seems like fast and i'm like
shook i don't know why just this
headline makes it seem fast they're
getting married on thursday it sounds
like they decided today to get married
in four days yeah today is thursday um
they're getting married today thursday's
always four days away right like they
got an aerial shot from like a
helicopter or a drone of a big tent in
her backyard like it's probably
happening like right now oh she's
getting married today right now as you
speak got it yeah no that makes sense so
yeah it does seem a little soon you
think they signed a prenup
no you don't
who's in brittany's life is going to
ensure the cheetahs right
i really hope she did
even though like i do think like their
relationship is solid but like you never
know yeah you never know but i i
don't think that she did what kind of
bride do you think um brittany's gonna
be it's definitely going to be giving
chuggy millennial for sure that's
britney's aesthetic and we love it yeah
no it's going to be
heart shapes everywhere i think cookies
say like she said yes maybe even a crop
top
she loves a crop top yeah i do wonder
like what her bridal aesthetic like
dress is gonna look like and like will
she be selling the photos to people
magazine or something like i feel like
she has fired everyone who does those
things for her yeah no i don't think
there's like gonna be some exclusive
like i think we'll see the pictures on
instagram like a normal person yeah
which is so crazy for like one of the
biggest pop stars in history yeah but
yeah she's not like that well hopefully
they have a photographer who can take
premium pictures yeah i'm sure there's a
photographer the it's not like a thrown
together affair like the picture of the
tent in the backyard like that's an
expensive tent tents are often the
biggest expense in a wedding and this
was like a legit one yeah
so congratulations hopefully tomorrow
we'll have some pictures to share some
news
but britney's doing what she wants to do
and that's all we wanted for her like
obviously her family sucks like it is so
sad to get married without your family
yeah like no matter like
obviously i'm not saying she should have
invited them just like conceptually like
being at a place where you can't invite
your family to your wedding is like
really sad well she's building a new
family she has her kids yeah and her
brother do you think kevin federline's
gonna be there
i have no idea he's really extremely
quiet throughout this whole
journey yeah
i wonder what he's up to where does he
live how does he make a living i think
he probably gets alimony yeah
but doesn't alimony stop if he gets
remarried only if kevin gets remarried
not brittany yeah oh
so he's probably not going to want to
rock the boat no totally he's cool she's
probably like show up behave yeah he's
fine with his situation not going to
weigh in on the conservatorship right
now it doesn't affect his check right
right right yeah that is so interesting
do brady's kids live with her full time
now no do they share custody like what
is the i think so
he's so interesting i think he probably
has a lot of custody yeah me too because
like for so long she like literally was
not near her kids yeah
but again i'm not the britney expert no
me neither there's plenty of podcasts
that are though though like solely
dedicated to it right anyways
congratulations
looking forward to seeing pics me too
are you ready for our next story yeah
robert de niro jokes about owning all of
taylor swift's albums he says i'm not
not a fan
turns out he needs energy when i read
this headline that it was being
sarcastic no i thought it meant that
like he was part of the company that
like owns her albums because every time
someone talks about owning her albums
they're talking about like who owns the
masters that's very true this is we're
triggered at this point i thought he was
like an investor in either like
buildings or the new one yeah he's
inadvertently owns her albums oh i
thought he was being sarcastic yeah i
own all her albums like i thought he was
being a dick
no so he opened up about his unlikely
taking to her music joking he owns all
of her albums speaking to variety about
the upcoming tribeca film festival the
actor and event co-founder um
were asked about their thoughts about
her screening her all too well short
film remaining this year or was that
last year this year now he um
was doing this some the interview with
the co-founder of tribeca so they were
just talking about tribeca
remaining tightlipped on whether or not
he's seen the project he noted he was
probably familiar with her music he
laughed and said i have all of her
albums i'm not not a fan i probably hear
her music and like it on the radio he
said my young daughter puts a station on
and it drives me crazy when they chat
when they have music it's okay by the
way um
robert de niro doesn't have like
siriusxm or an aux cord he okay well he
probably has serious xm but still
sometimes they like inject their
personalities yeah but like not a lot
that used to bother me so much too no no
like growing up as a kid who like was
like in the car all the time it was like
some of the low points of my life were
like literally the commercial break and
we only had like two more minutes to get
to our destination it's like put the
[ __ ] song on but not even the
commercial break when like the the hosts
are talking about themselves who would
want to listen to that
it's disgusting like when you're trying
to listen to music yeah or you have to
listen to like a war of the roses which
is
fake yeah oh well my like memory my
association with like listening to
people on the radio is elvis duran in
the z morning zoo and they used to do
those prank calls that's where the roses
oh yeah and those are fake
no yeah a lot yeah they're fake how do
you know because i worked in radio okay
and so do you have proof or is it a vibe
it was just like known i thought no i
mean i guess like when i was six like i
i feel like i'm telling people that
santa claus is no longer literally like
i mean like it was called what was it
phone tap yeah what the [ __ ] is war on
the roses wherever the roses it's like
i don't know hold on
well i guess when i was six years old
like the idea of it being fake like
wasn't a possibility to me but maybe if
i heard it now i'd be like that's so
obviously staged because i'm a jaded
queen yeah yeah
maybe some of them are real but how can
they have them all the time and people
don't know right
they bust cheaters
oh but that's not what
phone tap was what was phonetic just
like general prank calls like really
elaborate they would have like they
would have one of their listeners call
in be like i want to prank my husband
here's everything you need to know about
him yeah and they came up with like a
little concoction and it was like so
entertaining yeah but other than that i
agree like
it's kind of how i feel about concerts
like
when uh s like a celebrity is doing a
concert and they want to talk for 10
minutes after a song like
love you but like please don't yeah it
doesn't bother me like as much and now
it's like now
being a mature adult like i could listen
to someone on the radio like talk about
themselves you know and find it
interesting no but it depends did i tune
in for that
like when i listen to a podcast
for those people when i'm listening to
music the truckers for the radio are
here yeah because they're listening to
the radio someone's coming on and
talking about their day and they don't
want to hear it no i just want to listen
to taylor swift right people turn on the
radio i think with the sole purpose of
listening to music i would say maybe
like 10 of people like listen to like
am radio like weather news stuff like
that like
me radio was for music like let's stop
yeah but some people like love the
personalities they become such a part of
their commute and their day that's
extremely rare i just want to say elvis
duran is like elvis duran is one one in
a thousand ryan seacrest one in a
thousand howard stern one another bones
one in a thousand howard's turn you're
choosing talk radio you're not you're
looking for me right right right okay so
like yeah one there's you named three
do you know how many radio stations are
in this country three and three thousand
yeah
there's more hosts too but yeah so um
what was the story robert de niro oh
okay so um love that about him
i think robert whenever i hear of the
toronto film that's wait what is it
tribeca wall
um tribeca film festival i feel like my
association is like always robert de
niro did he start
he's heavily involved so yeah yeah yeah
there's no wonder why he's
interviewed yeah interview um we love a
man with quality taste and music and if
that doesn't say that taylor swift's
music is for all i don't really don't
know what will yeah it is for all it's
for all are you ready for our next story
some tea
jlo's halftime documentary shows that
jayla was unhappy to share the stage
with shakira as she should when jennifer
lopez had to share the super bowl
halftime stage co-headlining with
shakira in 2020 some including this new
york post writer and the host of the
morning toast wondered why jenny needed
anybody else on her block
although the two latina divas played
nice and hugged it out at the hard rock
stadium in miami it turns out j.lo
wasn't feeling so good about having to
squeeze in one typical headliner show in
the half time in half the time for the
halftime the 52 year old brock bronx
icon vents her frustration about it
during halftime her documentary that
opened at the tribeca film festival
making waves before premieres on netflix
june 14th so it comes out next week she
said
this was the worst idea in the world
says a pissed off jlo who was seen
fighting with the nfl for more time to
do her set justice while jlo doesn't
come right out and say why she had to
split her stage time with shakira her
long-time manager benny medina doesn't
miss mince words about the disrespect he
said it was an insult to think that you
needed two latinas to do the job that
one artist historically has done 100
we said that last time even though no
complaints about the show literally
shakira could have done it by herself
one year and jayla could have done it by
herself one year and don't forget also
like bed bunny showed up like it was it
was giving disrespect
and we felt that and i'm really glad she
acknowledges that because when i look
back on her show my first thought it was
is like wow she was incredible and my
second thought was like why were there
so many artists on stage right and when
we heard that shakira was joining her we
were just like question mark at the end
of the day though it was an amazing show
and they clearly made it work and you
can tell that she's such a professional
and she's gonna make space for shakir
because the nfl is forcing her to but it
was so unnecessary she has what it takes
she has the discography the the um the
choreography like she has everything
there was literally no reason for it not
to just be her and then maybe shakira a
different year yeah um and i feel
frustrated like on her behalf so i'm
glad she was frustrated too like what
yeah and it's just being honest about it
because you don't have to like lie okay
with everything all the time yeah and so
it's interesting to know that it wasn't
her choice and that if she had
had it her way it would have been just
her obviously like this is a once once
in a lifetime opportunity when you get
to like this level of fame like you want
to make it the best possible thing you
can be and you're constricted to half
the time but you want to perform all
your hits like that [ __ ] sucks yeah
and this seems to be a trend now yeah
the last time we had a solo halftime
show
oh that was last year okay
they go in on and off like coldplay
beyonce and bruno mars that one year
which was definitely weird because each
one of them could literally do five
halftime shows and they had
and they had already done it it was
coldplay's halftime show and then they
like brought out bruno mars and beyonce
who had already done their own halftime
shows but like that was really amazing
honestly it was incredible no but even
um the year that was maroon 5 and travis
scott
yeah well even this most recent year it
was like 12. a medley it's a medley and
now we're getting into halftime festival
and we need to we need to go back yeah
but they're like literally running out
of people who really are eligible in the
sense that their music is popular enough
they're but they haven't done that
they're not because they're forsaking
they put two in one year when they could
have had one in one right so they could
have had one running out of people
that's
no i know but like kelly clarkson
taylor swift and you know by the way we
didn't report on it but pepsi no longer
owns the halftime show
oh we did a while ago that the rights
were um were coming up and then it
should be the morning toast halftime
show yeah but so they didn't repurchase
it which now means taylor swift is
officially eligible for the halftime
show because her diet co contract
doesn't
impede on it so that's interesting um
wait let's keep thinking of people who
could do it by themselves
drake drake ariana grande i think she's
there yeah um
even a lot of people who did like the
medley this time around like could have
done by themselves snoop dogg mary j
blige like it's really i'm not into
half cella yeah no not at all and i'm
glad that
jayla's being honest too i mean some of
the other artists that have been part of
medleys like no they weren't doing it by
themselves i'm sorry yeah it wasn't
gonna happen of course so
that's nice for them what do you think
is the greatest halftime show like in
history oh i have so many favorites
bruno mars me too i love katy perry was
really good katy perry's
like i could re-watch it and love it but
at the time was the best thing i ever
saw she really was that [ __ ] like it
was the best thing i ever saw and she
had just come off of like hit after hit
after hit after like roar was like the
biggest song ever that was an iconic
moment for katie yeah i loved lady gaga
oh
same she gave everything she okay lady
gaga's up there too she was
beyond beyonce beyonce gave everything
everything but then we've had some some
not great ones like black eyed peas
justin timberlake
don't even don't i block that out you
know there's a blind going around that
people think is about just in timber
lake um it's like this is it nt or
dumois dumois
this um you know male pop star sometimes
actor
doesn't
want the world to know he's pretty much
almost bald
and i just thought that was interesting
i thought it also could have been about
harry styles
no but he's out there all the time with
his hair like rocking his head like
front and back but also the blind said
like his hair piece is so natural like
even an expert wouldn't know like okay
good for him yeah
there's so many things you could do now
for baldness if you want to i know
hair plugs i know a million people have
had hair plugs and they definitely look
like crazy in the beginning but then it
it naturalizes yeah rogaine rogaine like
things really work sugar bear hair
exactly
exactly sugar bear hair um so i'm the
more i hear about jayla's documentary
the more i am looking forward to it
can't wait and i just love especially
since gaga's was so good i love to watch
someone prepare in a documentary style
format for the super bowl for the honor
of a lifetime yeah it is it's up there
with the honor of a lifetime yeah what
else the platinum jubilee yes that's
what yes
the platinum jubilee no it's the
jubilee performance platinum jubilee or
the super bowl half time what would you
do this
hmm super bowl have time like more
people more people but more honor
no definitely i'm american like the
super bowl
i don't know more people watch a super
bowl
uh i don't we don't know the numbers of
platinum jubilee but um but wait also
like you then you're at the top of
itunes like and
i feel like when you do the super bowl
like everyone has an opinion like that
sucked but if you're in the jubilee like
it's just a part like a nice part of the
day you know like is there a green room
with kate and william no and by the way
um you usually share the stage at the
jubilee with other artists and
unless you're jlo but usually it's just
you at the super bowl and then there's
like so much fanfare before during
afterwards um i think i would choose a
super bowl
yeah if you ask me like six months from
now i'll probably choose a super bowl
but right now the jubilee is like so big
in my heart yeah you know i also would
like to apologize to our irish toasters
um i made the grave mistake of saying
that niall horan was british um and like
deep in my heart like i knew he was
irish but is that also still a part of
like the queen
or is that scotland no it's um
i think irish has independence now but
it's a it's a good question okay okay
but they were common misconceptions they
were once together
now they might be able to okay so i just
want to apologize like for saying that
niall horan was british i just meant
like the one i meant wonder okay
whatever yeah i know i know what i said
i was wrong so let me go um it's
separated from
geographically
so it's not under the commonwealth
is ireland an english country
english is the spoken language thank you
oh god is ireland part of the united
kingdom
northern ireland is
okay maybe he's there's
drama there yeah for sure
it's giving um branson
no that's the drama no it's giving
branson from downton abbey no that is
the job he was like a a renegade right
he didn't want ireland to be a part of
great britain got it yeah it's giving
branson but then he fell in love with
with an english girl and an english girl
and had english babies yeah spoiler
alert
are you ready for our next story no
get ready then okay
the next story is brought to you by the
olive and june manny system it is
everything you need for a salon quality
manicure in one box you can customize
your box with up to six choices um up to
six different polishes of your choice
their polish does not chip it lasts
seven days or more and when you break it
down it's just two dollars a manicure so
obviously what we love about olive and
june is the fact that we don't have to
go uh to a salon and hear your manicure
call you fat in spanish um
and it's just more cost effective like
two dollars a manicure and i love the
pouch that it comes in it literally has
a nail buff a nail file it has this
great silicone cap that you put on their
polish bottles that steadies your hand
so even if you're not great at nails
like you can get a really decent
manicure with olive and june like on
your right hand um their colors are very
like stylish trendy and pliny their
colors are gorgeous nobody has better
colors than alvin june and it just feels
good to have like a good manicure that
feels you know like and like you have
your life together to know that you can
do it yourself you know to have that
autonomy visit oliveinjune.com
tmt for 20 off your first mani system
that's o l i v e
a n d
j u n e dot com slash tmt as in the
morning toast for 20 off your first mani
system olivenjoon.com
tmt
you will love your new hands you'll love
them and you know what they are they're
just
hands our next story the latest viral
tick tock recipe mixes balsamic vinegar
and lacroix to make healthy coke a
tick-tock user has shared a
two-ingredient recipe that she claims
tastes like a healthy coke and the
internet has a lot of thoughts on monday
tick-tock amanda jones shared a recipe
for healthy soda alternative but users
are not convinced that it tastes like
coca-cola the original tic tac has
already amassed nearly half a million
likes and the internet is buzzing over
this even jenna and hoda
ma'am
um if you're looking for a healthy
alternative to coke why don't you try um
diet coke
yeah lit literally
this pisses me off obviously as a diet
coke aficionado let me tell you why
first of all like oh you think coke
never had the idea let's make a healthy
coke it's literally called diet coke it
has zero calories zero sugar like the
aspartame like might kill you but it's
fine like it's fine tasty but you'll
still be healthy
um first of all or coke zero coke zero
second of all like why
why
that's really where i'm left
what i'm left wondering is why
and it did occur to me to try this and
then i realized like i would literally
rather die than put balsamic vinegar
anywhere near my mouth like i think it's
the most disgusting substance substance
on the planet i think you need to try it
no and also like i wanted to make the
tik tok but basically like everyone sits
with like a cup of ice in front of them
and then pours the two ingredients in
but like my ice machine has been broken
for like a year and like i never got it
fixed like i'm just like embarrassed to
do without ice because that's also
really disgusting yeah that's nasty you
should just get a bag of ice from the
store yeah i will say though like when
people mix the ingredients together they
do
really look like diet coke because the
diet coke the lacroix makes it really
bubbly yeah and then the bottom is just
like black like diet coke i think you
need to try it on for all of us you're
our resident tick tock expert and you
get all of the pros and now
comes some of the responsibilities i
know i i really can't like i'm very
thirsty on tik tok and there's really
no length i won't go to to get the
content but
a line i will not cross is eating
balsamic vinegar like i think there's
nothing more disgusting or smelly on the
planet than balsamic vinegar i can't
believe people eat it do you still post
other tick tocks other than our morning
toast clips yeah like they make my own
trends but like i'm i'm definitely
trying to tell me um you know cute text
your husband sends you i'm not making
trends sorry you're like you're
following drugs
um but i'm definitely more heavy podcast
content now that's exciting yeah it's
great yeah i'm happy for you so that's
why i really i can't do this and i can't
subscribe and i just feel like people on
the internet like my god
you're willing to drink balsamic vinegar
just to save yourself like calories from
coke like
that is just a mindset like i just want
attention oh 100
and this is like things like this are
just why i actually came really close to
downloading tic tac yesterday actually
started the download and then canceled
it why because i wanted to look at that
page that you sent me about cars
jackie's thinking about getting a car
and i i don't follow but this girl's
always coming up she's like hey mamas
we're
reviewing the ford f-150 today is it
mama approved and she's like a lot of
followers and she gives like good tips
so i was like [ __ ] like you need a mom
car you need a mama mobile so and she
goes from top to bottom like top tiers i
think she does like porsches all the way
down to like more affordable she does it
all yeah so i really wanted to watch all
of her videos which is not something you
can do on safari and i was like okay
i'll download it to watch and then i was
like no
not so you're only doing yourself a
disservice because like you might not
get the best possible car because you
didn't follow mama car reviews yeah but
then i asked zach if i could look at it
on his phone
fraudulent no i just wanted to look at
it but it would just have been a rabbit
hole like i can't i can't go down there
um but then seeing something like this
like makes me feel really good about my
decision yeah no like i saw the original
video now i've been seeing like other
people trying it and most people are
like this is rancid and some people are
like i mean like i could see it like my
god you are so desperate
just drink the coke like i [ __ ] hate
this [ __ ] like i just drink a lacroix
you're so concerned right now aren't
there like a thousand brands that make
fake soda lollipop right
poppy mm-hmm like
stop like yeah no really stop have an
ollie pop literally or just have a diet
coke no but they like it when it tastes
like coca-cola they say
diet coke doesn't taste like coca-cola
it's better
of course but lollipop does
it's so twisted people are really sick
yeah no in the name of health they've
got too much time on their hands and
they also feel the need to share with
the world and yeah she was like my
pilates instructors
swear by this product like i'm sure they
do no i'm sure they do too and your
pilates instructor is not okay
she's unwell
she's done well well and the girl
drinking it the first time i was like oh
my god it's like literally coke i was
like shut the [ __ ] up no it's not
sorry like when you mess with diet coke
and like that's kind of where i draw the
line okay everybody has their boundaries
yeah
i just think this is like twisted
it is and i feel like when people are
always going on about like diet culture
about things that like i don't find
problematic i don't really understand
like toxic this is toxic to eye culture
yeah drink the [ __ ] soda [ __ ] or
don't order
drink water
juliana drink a lot of water
are you ready for our fifth and final
story already i know
is it
the final story
mess with my diet coke and i'll [ __ ] you
up
[ __ ] around and find out
gorgeous gregina gorgeous
our fifth and final story the grammys
has added new award categories to the
grammys the recording academy has
announced several new awards and rule
changes for the grammy awards new awards
include songwriter of the year
non-classical love
along with best score soundtrack for
video games and other interactive media
sorry that's one category sorry and the
special merit award for best song for
social change
okay
other amendments include changes to the
grammys entry and voting processes
including a rule that ups the minimum
new content for album eligibility from
50 to 75 i don't know what that means
all changes go into effect immediately
for the 65th annual grammy awards taking
place in 2023. don't get me wrong like
there are some songs for social change
that literally like shook the foundation
of which i walk
someday when we aren't six feet apart
that and
the one the one help the one don't look
it up we're gonna figure it out don't
look it up okay it's the disney channel
kids of course
the disney channel is kidding like we
are the world yeah that's what it's
gonna be
it was the disney channel version of we
are the world and it was like
amazing to make a better place so that
no that's what that's around
it goes like um
what i said
around and send it on
yes send it on
on and on
just one hand can heal another reach
apart
reach your heart
just one spark starts to fire
the one little action the chain reaction
will never
stop make a
[Music]
[Applause]
was nick jonas
gorgeous everyone came together to send
it on demi miley celina
brothers pepperdine university totally
gorgeous okay so
my caveat to that statement is like
while there are songs send it out that
change like literally change lives for
social change
i find a lot of the newer like social
justice songs like to be like really
cringey
yeah it's like get out and vote like
it's like
[Music]
and like you should
i support the message it's just like
it's getting cringe and i feel like this
new category is going to encourage
people to do more like cringy because
you can get a grammy it's going to be
like a lowly it's gonna be like a a
loophole yeah so like
while there are certain social justice
songs like lit we are the world like
literally change lives
i just feel like the newer ones are like
giving it's getting performative you
know beyond so and i think it's going to
encourage more performative measures
which we don't need yeah but that other
category songwriter of the year is
definitely something i i'm into yeah
because there's a lot of like you know
shane mcinally like behind the scenes
literally songland people yeah who
deserve shine yeah who deserve and they
win grammys when the artist wins grammys
but they deserve their own moment yeah
we should know who they are because
they're writing all these songs that
we're singing along it's so true like
normalize having songwriters be famous
yeah yeah but i feel like for some
songwriters it's actually a great job if
you don't want to be famous but you want
like that express yourself you want to
express yourself you make a ton of money
yeah but you can go to the grocery store
and i still feel like even with this
grammy you can maintain if that's like
the privacy you want you can maintain
that even with this new category maybe
it won't be on television yeah it'll
definitely be on like the loser one
nobody watches before yeah or they just
gave it out before and yeah you know so
i like that i think the grammy should
also work on the beat i think the grammy
should also update some of their
categories to um
like
you know stop cheating and like lying
you know yeah like make it merit-based
so yeah so just like who can create your
ass far enough that's my new favorite
maybe that's next year crawl up your ass
yeah like everyone's crawled up each
other's butts it's so true i'm so far up
your ass i'm about to come out your
mouth oh yeah we're up each other's
butts like in a positive way yeah no i
think it could be positive or negative
just like anything just like anything
just like life and you know what to that
i say send it on
that's such a good song i'm actually
going to go home and watch a music video
yeah
i remember being like
i have to recycle question yeah what are
we sending on is that about recycling it
was like reduced reuse recycle vibes
love it which is a great message
today yeah no i would watch that
i would watch out send it on video and
like literally go rummaging through the
trash like separating
separating my glasses my papers what a
song for social change should do right
but now it's just like you're one in a
million and like it's giving cringe yeah
send it on y'all but one heart can heal
another don't forget that and one spark
starts a fire i mean that's facts what
was that other one i think was like
mitchell musso like reduce reuse recycle
reduce me
that sounds like uh you know what's that
thing
reading roblox
something like that yeah you know
conjunction junction what's your
function
and also you know what's from that's
that from the reading railroad or
something i need to they said need to
look good wait you're going to quake do
you know what other song is from that
thing that we're talking about right now
uh
schoolhouse rock okay do you know what
else was from that what and that's a
magic number no that's from school of
rock
yes but do you know where he was
referencing it from school house rock
right how do you know that because like
somebody told me it on in the comments
when we started saying it a lot okay
cool yeah conjunction that was like a
sexy
it was like the kids version of marvin
gaye that song came out i was like
taking my top off
conjunction junction what's your
function like yeah
i could just see streis brothers and you
know what jackie
jay what is our function
well our function is to bring people joy
make people laugh get people from one
day to the next be a part of people's
every day and what is a conjunction
habit the
function of a conjunction is to make is
it like there they are yeah i think so
so it's kind of like when we put words
together we're doing conjunctions yeah
we love conjunctions right
that's like all we do like it's a good
story it's a gory
exactly that is it's a bad story it's
boring
and she sure smiles
teacher is happy that's not a
conjunction when teacher frowns teacher
is sad
sad it's not a conjunction okay
conjunction is a word used to connect
clauses or sentences or to coordinate
words in the same clause right dish
issues dishes
okay should we dive into our tv recap of
the real housewives of beverly hills
okay wait i just want to say
seven conjunctions these are the english
seven conjunctions there's only seven
yeah four and nor but or yet so so we're
totally wrong it's not a contraction so
it's just a word that what
used to connect clauses or sentences oh
okay so like
i'm feeling really great and i'm also
really tired and would be the connector
yes
and it's a really over complicated way
of just like
a contraction is what we're talking
about dishes
gory right
there
[Laughter]
depends which type of there i'm so glad
we learned all of this you know and not
how to pay our taxes contraction
traction what's your attraction
love
okay
oh okay are you ready i'm ready to move
on though that was really a nice trip
down memory lane just opened up a pocket
of my brain that i look forward to
delving into later well you're gonna
like have to get back into that soon
like when haroldson starts going to
school and he's like mom what's a
conjunction you're sitting there being
like there it's you know and i'm like
you just turn it on
junction junction what's your function
but i think it's a little inappropriate
that song it's very sexual
um okay let's dive into the tv recap
that's brought to you by thrive
cosmetics thrive cosmetics is amazing
they have high performance beauty and
skin care products that are made with
clean skin loving ingredients and the
name cause is in the name because every
purchase supports organizations that
help women thrive so they are known for
their liquid lash extensions mascara
which i have owned before they started
sponsoring the show because i saw an
extremely convincing facebook ad and
i've been using it ever since because i
have the worst eyelashes it is their
best selling product it is ultra
lengthening eye opening mascara that
lasts all day without clumping smudging
or flaking and it mimics the look of
lash extensions without damaging glue or
expensive salon prices it is clean
it has nourishing ingredients that
support longer stronger and healthier
looking lashes over time the removal is
super easy it's a tubing formula that
slides right off with warm water and a
washcloth there is no soap required they
also have great uh skin care products
like their sunproof three in one
invisible priming sunscreen so it's a
skin care and makeup hybrid it protects
with spf 37 and it perfectly um
preps your makeup and prevent the
appearance of aging skin from sun damage
so it's a lightweight hydrating gel that
applies clear on all skin tones they
also have a great mission it's bigger
than beauty for every product purchase
thrive cosmetics donates to help women
thrive so that's women emerging from
homelessness surviving domestic abuse
fighting cancer and more and now is a
great time to try thrive cosmetics for
yourself right now you can get 15 off
your first order when you visit
thrivecosmetics.com
toast that's thrive cosmetics
c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s
dot com slash toast for 15 off your
first order gorgeous i'm wearing the
thrive cosmetic sunscreen today and it
is my favorite sunscreen because it's
like a sunscreen primer and then clear i
never used a primer for my makeup
no i don't know i never got into one and
then i got this one from thrive and it
covers these two bases which are quite
important to me especially the sunscreen
very important especially this time of
year but you should really wear
sunscreen all the time which i do my
thrive cosmetics one i love it okay real
housewives of beverly hills was like an
episode that gave us like pretty much
nothing until the very end and i thought
the ending was so interesting up until
that like i don't really have any
thoughts like really um
sad about lisa rena's mom and i think i
saw like a lot of people being like
can't believe she went on the trip and
it's like normalize experiencing grief
and like still living your life right i
didn't think it was weird at all
normalize experiencing grief in your own
way like i don't think anyone could say
that like rina doesn't care heartbroken
about this so like also it hadn't really
hit her yet in the time that it takes to
hit her might as well try and enjoy
enjoy your life and i'm sure that's what
lois would have wanted right and really
hearing her talk about how like even at
her age the fact that she had a mom who
was 93 who could still hear
see like i was like so jealous and i was
like that is amazing so i actually feel
like her perspective on the whole thing
was really um
positive not positive but
healthy yeah and i think the other women
like kyle who obviously lost her mom
like a while ago like helping her come
to the realization of how blessed she
should feel um i really appreciated that
as someone who like doesn't even have a
dad i'm like you're kidding right yeah
no it was very very nice and also just
shows randa like as much as you know we
criticize her like she is committed to
this show
she will literally there was no way she
was missing this trip and it's not even
because she's not like grieving or
whatever like she's compartmentalizing
she's doing the job working and she's
also sharing and opening up like
that's really why we love rena and
that's also like what real people do
with their friends like yeah it was
extremely relatable and i just feel like
i actually respected her going on the
trip not i didn't think it was like a
classic thirsty rina like i didn't know
that no not at all um i did think an
interesting thing with rena just to skip
a little bit was like sutton brought up
this thing that like all these women in
society yeah they say about crystal
which is basically like crystal will
make things up about you like
beat you down and then become friends
with someone like on top of the ladder
um and in her confessionals lisa said
she was like yes i had heard this about
crystal but i decided not to use it yeah
which i just thought was like a really
interesting word for her to say as
opposed to like i just decided not to
bring it up yeah no it definitely like
kind of exposes like the way that the
women do use information about each
other on the show she was probably
keeping this in her arsenal in her
arsenal but also it's a hard even when
sutton said it it sounded like
conspiratorial and kind of crazy and
until rena said that in her confession i
would have been like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about yeah but i guess it's
like a thing and so i'm glad that rena
said it to the viewers so that like
watching that scene i had more context
and i was like oh sutton's not just
pulling [ __ ] out of here that's throwing
[ __ ] at the wall and yeah of course
maybe rana should have spoken up and
backed sutton in that moment but i also
didn't really need her to but yeah then
sudden she did i mean
it did sound kind of stupid because then
also she was doing exactly what they
were accusing crystal of like talking
about something but not sharing exactly
what it was so the crystal thing so i
feel like a lot of people are are
confused like sutton wasn't even mad at
first and now she is and i feel like
sutton got mad when she finally got
confirmation that the thing crystal was
talking about was the conversation about
the jacuzzi because i think maybe sutton
said like maybe did i accidentally say
something i didn't mean to be offensive
but that came off really offensive to
crystal so she was kind of like
tiptoeing around it and and that's why
she wasn't getting angry until she found
out that the thing crystal was talking
about was this big nothing burger how
did she find out that that's what it was
or was that christmas
crystal confirmed it at the table at the
table and and i think chris sutton when
at the lunch with garcelle was like i
mean the craziest thing i said
was the jacuzzi thing and
was what sutton said in the jacuzzi
problematic no if anything it was like a
little cringy and like it was giving
like you know like performative like all
welcome in my jacuzzi but there was
nothing mean-spirited or bad about it no
and two and i think garcelle backed her
up one going back to the initial reason
why we're even having this conversation
garcelle said when you said that to
sutton it
you wanted to
set her up and crystal said it was
because of something she said before
that but that conversation took place
the next day so the lie detector
determined that was a lie and wait and
she's going on and on about how kyle
doesn't remember it because she was
drunk uh kyle doesn't remember it
because she was in a different room
right so
it was really bad for crystal like she's
wrong and she's so you did want to just
say that to no matter what she said and
i felt like when garcelle said like you
set um sutton up i'm like that is so
random but actually
now that i'm like she got caught in a
major lie crystal i'm like maybe marcel
was right maybe marcel wasn't just like
being a potster no because even though
like that was her excuse for saying that
it actually happened the next day so
that's null and void and also eve like
crystal is
behaving so bizarrely because she was
upset with sutton for saying that she
doesn't see color but then the next day
she's talking about what she saw in her
jacuzzi seeing color all these different
people hanging out with her kids and
that's upsetting to her too so that was
where you said that she saw color that
she didn't see right that was sutton's
way of like kind of i think
resolving
or like making making it like like
justifying a little bit to what she had
said the night before so i don't really
understand crystal like at all yeah in
this scenario it was such a bad episode
first at the end of the table where like
everyone was just like calling her out
on her lives and she like couldn't say
anything like she looked like a huge
loser like it was really bad no she
really really did and i'm glad that we
all got and sutton got to the bottom of
what it was that was just gonna wonder
of course and it
it was a nothing nothing literally
nothing and obviously i'm not like an
expert on race so when when crystal was
like garcelle do you think that was
problematic and garcia was like no i'm
like okay i'm not missing anything right
it was so weird it was so weird and
what's crazy is crystal keeps saying
they're you know saying what words i can
and can't this is too strong that's too
strong and then kyle says well you're
gaslighting the situation she said don't
say that okay so the thing is is like
crystal getting hung up on everyone
getting hung up on her words um she
literally
is using the wrong words yeah there was
nothing dark about what
sutton had said and honestly
what was the other word she used last
season
uh violated
okay she was entitled to feel violated
she didn't say sutton violated me she
said i felt violent it's like she's
entitled to feel that but in this
particular scenario like literally talk
about using the wrong word like
dictionary definition merriam-webster
yeah and mercy webster define dark she
was also lying because that conversation
happened after the one from the night
before so now we have to go back to
garcelle's original point when you said
that like you didn't matter what sutton
said you wanted to set her up and you
know what um erica is making herself
look so bad because she's just doing
anything she's successful with going
against um sutton and so she was backing
up uh uh crystal a little bit at the
dinner and then next week she like tries
to gas like crystal into hating sutton
moore and it's making her look so bad
she has to get over it she's really
looking crazy bitter and evil but it
looks like next week it's mission
accomplished because sutton like kind of
loses just back away from the table like
her and it's exactly what
sutton and rinna said that crystal does
she like attaches herself to the
head-on show of the group to take down
the little people or people that she's
like not feeling and that's what she's
doing with erica and when they said that
about crystal i was like who is the
number one girl in this group i was
thinking the same thing
who is it it depends i do think a lot of
the time it's kyle but
because she's the og because she's the
og but she doesn't really get involved
you don't need kyle on your side or not
because it's not like rina you need rana
and erica but they're also like
not really least liked yeah i was
thinking the same thing so i didn't know
like which way she was climbing up the
ladder like to get to who and normally
when
someone interjects on someone else's
behalf as much as garcelle does for
sutton it drives me crazy but sutton is
like not good at being a housewife like
she could not go toe-to-toe with people
she her voice gets like trembly and
quakey and she starts to cry except she
was really strong last night when yeah
when she was talking to crystal i think
because she felt like finally like
i think the whole time she thought there
was something worse that she had said
and she didn't remember so i think when
she got finally confirmation she like
felt confident like i was saying
something nice yeah and then having
garcelle having her back i think that
gave her even more confidence and i
don't mind it when garcelle speaks on
behalf of sutton because first of all
she's consistently speaking facts like
deway garcelle in
less than is this her second season or
third third third has become one of my
favorite housewives of all time like she
is so
rational and it's just it's refreshing
to see someone be so logical even if
that sometimes means like questioning
their own friend you know yeah it's not
really and of course she always has
sutton's back but she was tight with
crystal and she was happy to like
point her a finger and be like
point out something that crystal was
doing i just love garcelle and it
doesn't bother me that she speaks up for
sutton in the way that she does because
if she didn't first of all nobody would
and and sutton has a hard time speaking
up for herself yeah and she's speaking
facts even next week it looks like she's
it says to like everybody you know gets
sudden to have a reaction and leave the
table and garcelle's like you are
bothering yeah like she is bothering me
yeah she really is i love garcelle like
that's love a couple weeks ago when we
were like we don't know whose side we're
on and the audience and it's so it's
even if sutton was on an island by
herself and like going against all of
the girls the audience is really on
sutton side or they were last season so
it's frustrating if like we're all
watching something and there's no one
on our behalf it's it's almost sad and
it's unfair and garcelle is a worthy
adversary she's a really good friend too
she's a really good friend and she's
just extremely like
like poignant like she gets to the point
she doesn't like start an unnecessary
drama like she go and a lot of people
think she's a potster but i feel like
she gets involved like when it's
necessary yeah and sometimes even like
last night with erica she kept like
bringing things up just so that the
conversation would continue i know and
but she was also helping us get to the
heart of the match yes i think you know
it looks like next week she's acting
extremely nefarious but sometimes i
don't and garcelle does that too where
it's like well why'd you say this you
said what what'd you mean like move it
along the conversation get somewhere yes
because when when i was like what i miss
and everyone's quiet it's like right
just get to it just get to it um diana
was pissing me off too i love her um
same but like her takes so far and
they've been insignificant are just bad
yeah it looks like next week she's
fighting with crystal with sutton which
doesn't work for me and of course she
has to back up her friend crystal but
like she's
she's really like full of kind of
atrocious takes
well she's coming into the group like
from a weird angle she's friends with
rana yeah who was beefing with sutton
rin is friends with erica and she's
friends with crystal who was beefing
with sutton yes so give her a minute to
get acclimated i'm just like beyond
confused by crystal like what was her
goal i don't know and then sometimes i
see her and like in a conversation and
she's so endearing and i like her so
much and then she'll get into it and i'm
like
and she has just like bad takes all
around yeah and she really is acting so
immature and when diana was like it's
because you're young like really maybe
that is what it is yeah i mean it is a
huge all the other women are well into
their 50s and she's third it's
definitely a factor but also a factor is
just her general bad takes yeah and
wrong this whole thing about i'm not
going to tell you what she said but it
was really really bad
immature and so wrong and the fact that
she got exposed and it was nothing makes
her look even more like crazy for not
saying it's like oh the whole time you
knew it was nothing she looks awful and
it was said after the original comments
full of lying yeah lies yeah gaslighting
lies yeah it's not good jerry was like
mia from the episode but obviously she's
like going through stuff yeah
so it was a good last scene but i was i
was like this episode sucks up until
then it was like just so much filler
yeah but seeing them on the plane was
fun thank you thanks diana truly they
all look so relaxed like they were all
still wearing their glam like it wasn't
typical like customs airport security
everyone just looked it just like fresh
a road trip it was so nice need a friend
like diana
we do we do
um that was real housewives of beverly
hills recap tomorrow will be the
kardashians recap
and that's our show that's our show oh
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday and youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found set
spotify itunes stitcher public radio
ihot radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
incredible thursday and we will see you
tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
send it on
on and on
have a great day bye